[Música]
vamos ahora las noticias de la economía
con Daniela Blandón Daniela nuevamente
saludo para usted Muchas gracias Ángela
Buenos días vamos a comenzar nuevamente
con la ode qué culpa de la inflación a
las grandes utilidades empresariales y
no a los salarios como veníamos pensando
Claro que sí la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económicos
publicó su informe anual sobre empleo y
en el advierte que entre diciembre de
2019 y el primer trimestre de 2023 las
cargas salariales como vemos se
incrementaron en 15,58% pero los
beneficios de las compañías lo hicieron
en 21,04% en el mismo periodo
en la mayoría de los países los salarios
reales por hora en realidad han
disminuido en promedio en el primer
trimestre del 2023 frente al año
anterior la caída es del 3,8% se puede
ver que la imagen por supuesto es muy
heterogénea entre países pero en varios
de ellos la ganancia unitaria ha
aumentado más que los costos de mano de
obra humana es inusual que en un periodo
de debilidad de la actividad económica
las ganancias aumenten esto es un tema
de preocupación
y frente de ese tema de preocupación hay
que destacar En todo caso la situación
de América Latina que nos muestra
algunas otras cifras pues la ocd realizó
un análisis de cómo se han comportado
los salarios en sus países miembros
desde diciembre de 2020 hasta mayo de
este año y descubrió Que bueno hay datos
de 32 países que hablan de que en 11 de
ellos el salario mínimo en términos
reales quiere decir que descontamos el
impacto de la inflación ha disminuido
pero tra una buena noticia para México y
es que este país es el que más ha
incrementado su salario real salario
mínimo con más del 40%, muy por encima
de la media el comportamiento contrasta
con Estados Unidos en donde el salario
real ha caído un 14% en este mismo
periodo en este último país el descenso
es más fuerte que todas las otras
naciones analizadas vamos a hacer un
cambio de tema vamos a irnos hasta
Estados Unidos que abrió una
investigación en contra de por problemas
con uno de sus modelos estas noticias
siempre son de mucho interés para
nuestros usuarios Claro que sí son muy
recurrentes además la administración
nacional de seguridad del tráfico en las
carreteras dijo haber recibido 118
quejas sobre una posible falla en los
puntos de soldadura de las puertas
delanteras en vehículos Ford Escape
modelos 2020 y 2021 por eso de inmediato
abrió una investigación sobre
346.000 de estos vehículos utilitarios
deportivos que están en el mercado
que una falla como esta podría resultar
en una puerta abierta repentinamente
mientras se conduce por ahora la agencia
dice que tiene 25 informes de lesiones
menores y también un reporte de daños
materiales menores el ligados a este
incorrecto funcionamiento de las puertas
de estos vehículos pues uno se pregunta
qué es lo que pasa Daniela porque como
usted dice fallas de este tipo se ven
casi que todas las semanas no Sí señora
todo el tiempo y en todas las marcas no
es solamente una todas las marcas
muestran esas fallas bueno se trata de
nuestra seguridad vamos a hablar ahora
de la inversión extranjera en América
Latina que ha marcado un nuevo récord
entre 2021 y 2022 este rubro se
incrementó en
55,2% en la región esto de acuerdo con
la comisión económica para América
Latina y el Caribe que es la agencia de
Naciones Unidas que vigila la economía
regional en términos absolutos esta
cifra alcanzó más de 224 mil millones de
dólares es el máximo valor anotado desde
que se tienen registros ahora veamos por
países el principal favorecido de esta
inversión fue Brasil la principal
economía de la región con 41% del total
de las entradas seguido de México Chile
Colombia y Argentina y tienen ustedes en
pantalla Cuáles son los porcentajes para
cada uno cerca de la mitad de estos
recursos fueron empresas que ya operaban
en los países y la cepal dijo que uno de
los grandes retos es que esta inversión
No se concentre en una sola ciudad sino
que también pueda ser distribuida a lo
largo de todos los territorios ahí en
sus cifras de china coqueteando con
América Latina Ah sí desde hace varios
años
vamos ahora a Japón para repasar una
noticia que nos contaba en la primera
hora y que no solamente tiene que ver
con economía sino que tiene que ver con
los derechos de los ciudadanos lgbtiq
más en Japón pues este caso involucra al
Ministerio de economía comercio e
industria y es el primero del tribunal
supremo de Japón que se relaciona con el
entorno laboral para las personas lgbti
una funcionaria del a la que se le
asignó el género masculino al nacer
presentó una demanda porque solamente se
le permitía usar baños de mujeres a
varios pisos de distancia de su oficina
en Japón las personas transgénero
solamente pueden cambiar legalmente su
género si se han sometido a una cirugía
de reasignación pero ella no pudo
hacerlo por razones de salud después de
mucho si decides y venir es judiciales
finalmente la Corte Suprema de Japón
dictaminó que las restricciones a las
que fue sometida son inaceptables y
también son ilegales el Ministerio
respondió a la decisión dijo que va a
examinar detenidamente el fallo y que va
a tomar las medidas apropiadas una de
las medidas que le habían pedido era que
Sencillamente pusiera un baño cerca del
sitio de trabajo de esta persona que
parecería algo
pues básico no que todos necesitamos
exactamente y no tener que subir varios
pisos para poder ir al baño pues Daniela
Gracias por traer esta noticia a la mesa
Le deseo que tenga un feliz resto de
jornada y nos vemos mañana para más
economía Igualmente Ángela Muchas
gracias